we have seven thousand three hundred
twenty nine minus six thousand two
hundred and seventy eight so let's go
place by place and see if we can
subtract 6278 is clearly less than seven
thousand three hundred and twenty nine
so we should be able to do this so first
we go to the ones place we're
subtracting an eight from a nine that
seems pretty straightforward that's just
going to be a 1 a 1 in the ones place it
literally just represents one then we go
to the tens place and we're trying to
subtract a seven from a two and this is
really representing a 70 and this is
really representing a 20 well now we're
hitting a bit of a stumbling block so
we're going to have to regroup or borrow
and to understand what we're doing let's
rewrite both of these numbers so seven
thousand three hundred twenty-nine seven
we can rewrite as being equal to seven
thousand plus three hundred so this 3 in
the hundreds place is representing three
hundred the seven in the thousands place
is seven thousand three in the hundreds
place is three hundred the two in the
tens place this two tens or 20 and then
the nine in the ones place is just going
to be nine
so this is another way of representing
seven thousand three hundred and twenty
nine and then down here we have the six
in the thousands place well that's just
going to be six thousand or subtracting
so minus six thousand and then here in
the we have a two in the hundreds place
and once again we're going to be
subtracting all of these so we're going
to be subtracting two hundred and then
here in the tens place we have our seven
we have our seven and we're subtracting
it so seven tens that's seventy and then
we have we are subtracting that eight we
are subtracting that eight and what
we've already done what we've already
done is said a look subtracting 8 from
nine that's just going to be that's just
going to be one but then we got over
here and we said hey how we're going to
subtract 70 from 20 and the key here is
to regroup some of the value up here and
give it to the tens place so that we can
subtract 70 from it and the most natural
place to go is one place value above so
we could take a hundred
it from the 300 so we could take a
hundred from the 300 so then it will
become 200 we're going to give a hundred
- we're going to give that hundred to
the tens place so it is going to become
it is going to become 100 120 notice 200
plus 120 is 320 300 plus 20 is 320 we
have not changed the value of the number
we've just changed what place we're
representing it in if we wanted to do it
here we could say and this is kind of
the you know when you think of it this
way this is really regrouping and this
is really what's happening but if you
want to think of it in a borrowing
framework you could say hey let's take
let's take one from the three although
that's a 300 so you're really taking 100
that becomes a 2 and you give that one
to the tens place and so that becomes
that becomes a 12 now what was really
happening is you took 100 you gave it to
the 20 it became 120 but now you can
subtract here you'd say well what's 120
minus 70 well 120 minus 70 is going to
be 50 over here you could say well
what's 12 minus 7 well that's 5 but
still representing the same thing 12
tens is 120 seven tens is 70 and they
give you five tens which is the same
thing as 50 this 5 represents that 50
and then we can go the other places you
say 2-2 well that's 0 hundreds and then
7,000 minus 6,000 is 1,000 and once
again right over here 200 - 200 is 0
hundreds and then 7,000 minus 6,000 is
1,000 1,000 so this is going to be 1,000
plus 0 plus 50 plus 1 which is the exact
same thing as 1051 the important thing
is to visual you don't have to write
this out every time but to make sure you
visualize in your head that this 3 is
representing 300 that this 2 represents
20 that when you're when you're taking a
hundred from the 300 then you would
represent that as a 2 in the hundreds
place and then when you give a hundred
to the tens place it's essentially like
adding it's essentially that the the two
tens will become 12 tens because you're
giving it 10 more Tanjore giving it a
hundred so hopefully that makes some
sense
you